congratulations  you  are  worthy  and remember  reality  is cursed  you're not special  you are fire  sorry eviction noticed  this used to be a good neighborhood  [Music]  what's this  cursor with 125 grand prize there are a  ton of unclaimed prizes from retro games  could be easy money you know wilkie's on  37th  yes i do meet me there tonight at 1 30.  it's a date it's a deal  [Music]  it's not like anything i've ever seen  before it seemed to affect reality  you have to choose kayla choose or die  clean up  [Music]  [Music]  how is it doing that it's almost putting  the words on the screen before i say  them  i don't see how video games could kill  someone the more the cursed suffer the  more the curser benefits  [Music]  if it sent you here it can't be for  anything good it's gonna hurt  we gotta choose caleb  [Music]  [Music]  you